what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba here and it's John the hump over
here we're going to talk about spoilers
for the movie we wonder wonder guy
wondering yeah wonderful I think they
should have just changed Wonder Woman
into a black guy I think that would have
been very like it's diverse do like it
ethnic because those usually it would be
weird yeah they'll be weird that would
be like I would love to see what
happened if that happened what the
discussion would become like I think
people's mind would melt yeah totally
this is weirdly
always this kind of maybe progressive so
we're going to talk about Wonder Woman
right now and our spoiler reviews tend
to be a little over the place yeah just
as a heads up because we're kind of just
spitballing and remembering and I'm
going back yeah yeah
film but I don't know that we could just
hop right into it from the beginning of
it this song starts off the first thing
you see is a scene in The DaVinci go
kinda hovering over a deluge yeah and
then the Wayne Shrek Walt and I never
expect Robert lay ahead like you
followed your slide I never liked him
I'm they mean Diana Prince and then
she's the daughter of Jesus yeah
so the the Wayne truck rolls up and
honestly you know a lot of times when I
see tie-ins this weird thing where I
just kind of get a little annoyed right
there my weird reaction where I'm like I
shouldn't because it's just the way it
is
yeah and it is established as far as
universe but I kind of get this like a
weird frustration that kicks it well for
thought before we make anything was
before we like going show you spoilers I
want that to be a preconceived notion we
love this movie oh yeah you watch our
non-spoiler we love love really also
movie yeah
I went on Twitter little the best
superhero movies ever yeah I mean there
there are things you can you can there
knits you can pick but overall man I
think it's pretty serious so when it
starts off with tying yeah not exactly
right now you know I felt like it's not
two in the theater cause like the second
those the first thing you see is a truck
that says weight on it and I was like
and the DC EU has annoyed me more than a
lot of more than some other movies with
this [ __ ] with this stuff so yeah see
and see a lot of weighing right up front
I was a little bit like oh here yeah and
you know and they so explain exactly
what it is Dianna's job at CVS or to
make that clear pound really care so
whoa so and then she opens up the email
we get the photograph again and and then
it goes to the origin because Dewey Cox
needs to remember his entire life worry
buddy because it takes place during be
be a dad so yeah you know when you're
talking and I was talking about the the
last scene later on but that even though
I'm a snob attitude caked in and I was a
little annoyed with the way how they
brought that scene back in the end made
it rewarding and thought availing and
the tie in annoyance completely
obliterated by the time the last scene
rolled around and I think truthfully
might have made it a meaningful time
yeah and I feel like truthfully and it
was something it was a way to make a
moment out of a problematic film better
yeah and in hindsight I will give them
that I mean part of what my frustration
was at that in my knee-jerk frustration
was with the first book end of this
movie was just like I want this movie
just to be allowed to do its own thing
and since it's a period piece it's not
yeah tied into any of the other movies
directly I just wanted it to be able to
breathe on its own and thankfully it
does it does and so as we hop into the
origin tale you know starts off at one
is primarily a hemisphere oh yeah you're
double Towson's review on this I haven't
listened anything
until we shoot the reviews I try not to
coral Corey hated a little little Diana
really a little Diana so much oh no I
thought they're just terrible actress
but we saw Olivia was with us and one of
the first things Olivia was telling me
and when after movie was done with how
she loved that she loved a little girl
touch and I didn't think about this but
talking to a woman a female about the
little girl when she's seen the warrior
woman punching and kicking and don't do
that all right this is a superhero movie
and women don't know anything what she
had to say is relevant or comunism ended
a sarcasm for this in case you were had
two people that are gonna comment I've
got a Twitter in there positive review
of what happened but she was telling me
how how she loved that touch and said
because she was like ah she was telling
me I should remember being a little girl
and loving Wonder Woman and doing that
thing where you're like you just want to
be Wonder Woman your little girl like
Duty kicks and punches yeah when you're
a guy and you like you watch spider-man
or something or Wolverine you know but
yeah yeah we've all done that so it does
harken back to that child of childhood
love and I loved everything on that
mascara I loved everything there
specifically it was Robin Wright who I
really did enjoy a helican blog we have
her name here general eye and antelope
and patio pew general at nto hurt her
strength and her presence and the way
she carries herself yet she wasn't just
tough woman you know I appreciated that
the Amazon warrior women weren't just
tough women they all had a vulnerability
there and that's why they became tough
that honey they trained so hard because
of their experiences that have hurt them
that had they're required to be tough
ass [ __ ] all the time well yeah I
mean it is a feminine society and
actually like I thought it was really
cool to see that depicted on screen just
just a oh yeah a nation of women yeah
when I was watching the training
sequences in the beginning I kept going
whoa whoa yeah like when they're riding
or even just when Diana's watching them
as a little girl like holy crab these
are so good because it's cool cuz
they're not CGI there's some women who
are doing them yeah and that's that was
like the really impressive part to me
was these are awesome stunt women yeah
they hired a lot of they put a lot of
people there and a lot of different
kinds of people you know yeah a lot of
different like races depicted on screen
and part of the culture like they did a
good job making it Iverson I agree with
you like it's not just like Oh woman
Society it's like people are are an
amalgamation of masculine and feminine
traits and and that is beautifully
depicted in this you know like they have
to fight they are a warrior tribe and
that's you know arguably a masculine
type of thing but there's also a strong
feminine tone to their society too you
know that's a well-rounded depiction of
their society I thought yeah for the
little glimpses you get you don't get to
just spend all your time but yeah yeah
and I mean this set design was great the
production design was awesome all the
cinematography of the island everyone
was amazing but going back to Jenner nto
rum right there her whole performance
there was something about I still can't
quite cuz you know she doesn't have much
screen time in the film she's just such
a standout player to me yeah maybe
because she's like the tough one who
really believes in Diana becoming who
Diana's meant to be and and I like and I
liked a Connie Nielsen stance on how she
doesn't want Diana to hone in because if
Diana becomes who she's what she really
is
then that leads Ares F that's such a
neat touch Tamia of if Diana becomes who
she's meant to be that makes it more
likely for Ares to come back yeah yeah
and that's a real conundrum yeah it is
see two of the most prominent leader
leader figures in her life you know have
to debate a tough debate yeah is a great
you like do we really have Diana repress
who she is
yeah or do we have her embraces she is
because I'm a mom Robin right side
energies Brian's going to come back yeah
never debated would agree yeah he's
going to come back we just gotta get her
ready yeah and and the decision-making
that was going on
you know I like I love how Diana's mom
kept switching back and forth
don't trainer and then okay make her the
most lethal warrior you can be and then
when she does we're going to do this and
we're gonna do yes because I love the I
love the Wayde Robin right train cyanide
generality of trains Diana you know that
the whole see were she's kicking ass
Diana when she's training with a warrior
woman and then you know and then ante up
comes in and provoking her keep your
guard up don't put your guard down this
is a blast and then come on sis like oh
[ __ ] was I any good yeah oh this is what
exactly what I was worried about tough
day in the office
oops God powers man I was worried about
this happen I have explained this to
everybody I was waiting to you yeah
exactly
but I also liked the touch of how they
kept that kind of a mystery for those
who don't know Wonder Woman that's and I
don't manage it perfectly honest I don't
know if that was change for the film
there she's the daughter of don't think
it is I'm pretty sure she is the
daughter of Zeus and having that be a
secret to Diana was great now she
doesn't because I thought up they're
going to tell her you know before she
leaves the island I thought that's what
was going to happen come to find out you
watching which is appliance at the end
of the movie yeah yeah I like that touch
because it's about the whole movie she's
discovering more and more of what she's
really capable of well that's a super
important thing for I think that that is
a beautiful choice because the whole
movie is about her finding out that dark
and light exists together and that's the
lynchpin for her is like oh yeah I am
part of the thing I hate yeah you know
and okay so Steve Trevor shows up and
that was a great scene I even love the
shot where it's that it's from Galvez
room behind gal gadot and then it
circles around her
she's just staring making a decision is
when it comes back around her than she
dives in that she's contemplating for a
while yeah like I don't know that is
innocent but I think I gotta go sunny
thing I got so bad I kind of go find out
who this person is well I thought the
physics to of like the the weird like
just curtain wrist in time yeah the way
they play with that how they kind of
transition from Earth is it a mascara
and you've got like the other soldiers
in the back was poking their hair
through and then from the trailer I
wasn't expecting that to be an actual
battle yeah yeah and I thought that was
a really cool decision and that was cool
because they're building up the the
warrior room the whole time and they can
they honestly seem like they might be
invincible in some way but when they
show up and they're battling guns a lot
of them are dying yeah and then that
threw me off because I thought oh
Amazonia is going to show up and take
all these soldiers no problem Steve
Trevor has captured but then the touch
of because I watched one of the trailers
again I'm like oh they revealed that
that woman who's swinging gets shot they
show that part in the trailer and I was
a little surprised Google when I saw the
movie I was surprised I went oh [ __ ] no
you know the first words I said oh she a
little bit yeah and that whole battle
sequence is awesome I love action that's
that's like Robert Reich just kicks ass
a whole pod it kicks ass and I love how
she I was surprised they killed her off
so early like she died early in the film
which is you know a superhero trope a
little bit the mentor yeah I was a
motivating factor yeah I must kind of
avenge you I also remember back to your
teaching yeah exactly and avenge you
like through principal and some Steve
Trevor picks up where the film really
takes up the siege ever shows up in from
the film picks up entirely
you know the whole lasso of truth scene
when he's being tied I thought that was
formed that perfect yeah man Chris Pine
and he he was next
oh yeah movie like Oh then and then you
can yeah you can see it in spaces as
well I said it it doesn't matter now I
guess I'm just going to tell you yeah
I'm going to stop trying to fight this
yeah and I appreciate the
decision-making of no one supporting
Diana's choice to want to help out in
the war I appreciated that the
Amazonians are like not doing this and
the whole scene with Steve Trevor and
our he's naked in there and then you say
the butt-naked headshotted see yeah
surprised we didn't they acknowledge he
didn't a professional but yeah what's
that this is and I love how he didn't
create any sexual desire for Diana and
nothing yeah yeah I'm not I was going to
go down some funny sexual tension scene
yeah I know it's like really awkward
yeah agra for him and she's like big
deal yeah your nape lesson what hasn't
seen this in a book yeah I get it and
that whole scene was great and the
description of the watching and is every
scene would Steve Trevor and her build
so well memories every time they're
together it adds another layer to their
relationship it's more than plot plot is
character every single time and Diana
you know stealing the sword and we're
going to the whole mood with you but you
know what yeah yeah basically it's
that's it's really nice that they made
it not so much about like oh these two
characters are learning about the plot
it's like they're getting to know each
other like throughout the movie they get
to know each other in different
situations and that's smart right and in
that scene when Diana makes the big jump
and that climbs the wall is that her
discovering she has super strength I
guess kind of like she seemed really
surprised like oh yeah just my hair yeah
rough don't matter me and that's what's
stopping non-spoiler it
I love this CGI transitions it's a real
life of the human characters like when
she's at that Tower
we're trying to get the sword and the
god killer sword and when she jumps in
CGI but when she when she's back in
human form and it's seamless it
transitions perfectly and I love the
transition of CGI to human because it
makes the CGI even more impressive to me
when they do that well yeah that was the
CGI jump cut she's real you know yeah I
feel like they they use their CGI pretty
well in this movement feel felt like
they did what it was necessary and they
blended it in well like they seemed like
they knew how to gotta use it yeah yeah
yeah and they go and after they leave
the famous Kira and they're on the ship
I love the whole dialogue that forms
between Steve Trevor and Diana or Diana
is a confident seems much more
comfortable with her sexuality will
hundun and that's an argument I've never
seen a man but she seems way more
confident with her so a woman and see it
seems like uncomfortable it wants to be
respectful and not like you've never
seen a man before huh let me let me
grace you it I look at real like when it
goes to sleep she comes behind her room
yeah like you brought up is guarded from
her is muscles yeah I'm gonna give you
your space Peter stay already sleepy
they'll sleep it off so beautifully them
talking because I love that yes the
people that won't think about like I
guess we don't do we for pleasures sake
you're pretty yeah so it's like wow man
when their kudos because a lot of the
time when I see these comic-book movies
that have like sex jokes or penis jokes
or whatever guardians to I mean a lot of
times it seems like weird to me it seems
a little out of place honestly it kind
of throws me off here because I know
that you're swinging for the kids
yeah you know and here in this scene
when they have this they just they talk
about they just flat-out talk about what
is that they act sure country dance that
is also funny in the end any two adults
try to communicate about a decreased
sexual tension in just the right way
you don't mean like
corny music boop mic or a comedy or like
a clumsy routine yeah like just seemed
like a real awkward situation for Steve
to be in it's like it's like
intellectually sexy oh yeah yeah yeah we
don't literally just a nice surprise
yeah and then when they go to London and
I mean I just really love the way Chris
Pine responds to everything
Diana pens and like this is London and
she says like it's hideous or something
yeah we have not for everybody
yeah I thought again I know we're
talking a lot about Chris Pine but I
feel like he does he's he's a surprise
that's the thing he's a delightful
surprise to it one especially we thought
a superhero yeah he's a big part of what
makes us feel so great and he has to
carry a lot of little nuances because
this is a guy who like you know just at
the beginning of this movie like his
perception of reality has to change yeah
catch him having to remember those
things like you Diana you know as a fish
out of water but oh yeah but she does
come from this like other world so like
means you have a point about something
stuff I don't know Hank yeah and it's
cool because even though she doesn't
need protection he's not aware that she
can just protect herself at all cost
yeah but when they're walking through
London and she starts taking off her
road no I got where anything yeah and
for a different place are like the
little fish I don't watcher touches I
thought were really nice that added
layers to Diana where she sees a baby
baby yeah no no no do a lot of like to
stop isn't it we go grab one of the
other day on track we got to go to the
front to fight area is it okay that I
love a character is constantly trying to
make keep things cool yeah my favorite
kind of characters who were the ones who
what's on edge there's a lot of [ __ ]
that suspenseful in their brain but they
guess I don't mean the kind of cool that
cut me a break I'm working at the end I
can't hear ya and the introduction of
edit can
was fantastic I mean right when she
shows up and and instead of taking
insult when Steve section ever says
she's my secretary she doesn't know what
his secretary is and she goes we call
that his slave and I love that it kandi
wasn't offended she was like I like I
like I agree yeah yeah you may okay good
so you stand you're standing up for me
right yeah yeah
Society will not let us say that right
now yeah yeah yeah and that's one thing
that I thought was very impressive
because you could have done sure maybe
you could have done some wonder woman's
story in modern day perhaps but to
specifically have the origin tale at a
time where female repression was that
like who is really high yeah much higher
than I mean it's so tiring some ways
than now yeah okay but like feminist
movement is is it accepted thing now I
think yeah you're aware you know like
where it's more aware of women are equal
we shouldn't be treating women any less
and all those things like this at a time
when we can even vote yeah nobody may
know that yeah something about that's
how we'll get the vote
yeah Rana and I like when she's like
scenes it just makes you love Diana her
character more and more when when she's
clothes shopping and she's like how can
you fight him you know absolutely a
woman wouldn't think about back then
that's what she's concerned about how
are we supposed to protect yourself and
I don't like because are credibly
interrupted oh yeah or when she has a
dress when I was lifting it up and run
it in a public place so it was so much
fun the entire time
yeah so as the film's for dressing and
even the meeting the first applause that
comes from the crowd that we saw with
was a moment that wasn't even aim and it
wasn't an action scene whatsoever it was
when she goes into the room with all the
people were Ares is that today dude and
I just decided bar man I'm actually
angry that they did that like I said I
ever feel that it's Ares yeah that seems
like a movie news yeah yeah that seems
like a really tone-deaf thing to do it's
like whoever made that decision didn't
read this script it makes the plots was
completely ineffective yeah it it
doesn't ruin it because I think they
still did a good job with it but it kind
of ruined what was a beautiful Miss
yeah you know yeah cuz when I was
watching the movie I started thinking oh
maybe they got the casting room maybe
maybe the announcement was wrong yeah
not Aires maybe they just thought he was
being casted Aires is David Gilles looks
like a pervert so the time he was yeah
they there's something about the way
they handled everything in the way he
plays a sir patrick then yeah that made
me even start to wonder like maybe
that's not I was gonna go down yeah um
but yeah uh famous Ernest and when she
shows up in the room with the people and
every woman doing in here Robin why is
she talking to us yeah and it seemed
more of her skill set like of how she
can speak so many hundreds of languages
and but that moment that everyone got
applause from because she says something
to the general that still is relevant to
today yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna lose
lying that's something about how you
give orders from your office accra five
soldiers while you're just here a real
general light from on the field with
with your soldiers will start applauding
yeah don't use your cooped up in the
room acting like life don't mess no no
that's what I knew for sure we had an
amazing character on our hand because we
didn't need an action scene with her
yeah they're in applause we just needed
to hear her beliefs I am Diana Prince
got applying for whatever yeah exactly
yeah that's that's the whole point of
that yeah but which led to a great scene
yeah rate scene afterwards when see
Trevor in the front will do that yes
just protocol and get that the lasso
yeah now MoMA is so funny man there are
so many laughter I was slapping my in my
knee man where you record the front
probably you're not yeah we have the end
away like the movie is clearly concerned
not with like how do we force our plot
to work with like everybody behaves like
this means something yeah like that that
choice to grab the last I'll be like
look I'm not lying to you we don't have
time for this yeah it's great
any assembly of the team was fun Samir I
don't know what ethnicity he is but Arab
or something that's what I thought um
yeah the middle idea I thought it was a
Middle Eastern mystery Middle Eastern
descent and he's the master of disguise
the ends up wearing a lot of different
kinds of outfits yeah and I like I like
the the foreign language dialogue taka
they were having with each other when
she getting meets Wonder Woman battling
the somewhere oh yeah I know it's more
likely yeah that was a great it's a
great touch and even when they
introduced the guy from Trainspotting
even bren-bren knew as Charlie because
because I thought I thought that was a
good play on cliche when they cut the
guy's punching and you think oh that's
Charlie I believe that I thought that
was the guy they were talking about
anything that's not sure what the guy
getting his ass kicked yeah that was a
really funny touch there and and so yeah
when they're having that whole exchange
and part of the great sell to of David
Thewlis when he shows up I'll fund this
trip to help you out that was wonderful
it was wonderful in it that's what
that's the moment when I thought oh I
wonder if they got I wonder if the
casting announcement was wrong like
maybe they just assumed he was playing
Ares and coz that scene really sold me I
believed him I'd like to shoot out of it
I did say I like this guy seems like
he's trying to do the right thing and he
can't he recognizes you and and here we
go because it's a great mystery cuz it
makes you like him a lot in that one
moment it's like the way patty Jenkins
captured the movie doesn't doesn't do it
in a way we were like I'm internationals
purser so this time yeah I mean cuz you
have all these different levels of
people who are immersed in the protocol
so it's like because a lot of what
Wonder Woman n does you've ever argue
about is the protocol it's like you
can't just bust in and do this there
there are things other things at stake
and so like I feel like even Steve
Trevor and Sir Patrick have that
normally when they're always on the
phone he's like no don't do that
yeah there's
stop it think yeah yeah they seem like
genuinely concerned yeah so when they
finally get to they get to Germany they
meet chief cheat if you gene brave Rock
whoa man native Native Americans have
the coolest names
yeah like legit Native Americans have
the coolest name Eugene brave Rock Wow I
would kill to have a name like that yeah
and having to carry it and you pointed
up and then the not so letter review
having this diverse cast but not but not
like throwing in our face lookout
diverse we are and I guess it seemed
like the team they assembled and you
know during wartime especially here in
an international setting you're going to
see one yeah and to be and I thought for
a movie that takes place during a war
and it's pg-13 it still you can still
because you're feeling it through Wonder
Woman shoes the how disturbing this is
as you can see Diana wasn't prepared for
the horrors that are inflicted upon not
just soldiers but civilians yeah when
she's when they arrive in Germany and
they start seeing all the people that
are like that limbs blown off and all
the tire V all the regular people who
seem injured and heard the distraught
and she's really caring for them and
they're they're building it so well
because it's going on for a while and
then when they meet chief and they have
the scene with Charlie where he wakes up
and he's traumatized and I love that
because I'm like this team is team
characters they're all carry out having
a light up yeah they're not like just
here's your one note you're supposed to
be it it's all have like specific
because when you first see Charlie eyes
the funny Scottish drunken only does
this for the money then you see all
kinds of really traumatized dude yeah
and I feel like that part of what's so
magic about this it comes out in in
things like that because the movie is
also very compassionate in that way it
takes time to notice the little nuances
of people and like there's that moment
with Charlie where she chooses to
empower him yeah even though she's kind
of like ragged on him and when she first
meets him while you shoot people from
far away that's a cowardly thing to do
and then when he's about to leave she's
like who's going to sing for the thing
yeah and that was such a wonderfully
beautiful because it's weird they felt
like a real Pete yeah
like they felt like a legit team and you
can feel that choice the GI in there you
know and so when they're when they're
going through the rich people and they
are going to Africa what battle it is
that what it was called well there
there's a yeah basically there's that
whole scene in no man's land no man's
like that's where is no man's land and
their people Steve Trevor's like we
gotta keep moving we can't save everyone
because he's not a good argument like
he's making a stop for every side quest
yeah I'm never beat the game yeah
exactly because I was like I agree with
Steve you can't save everyone you gotta
you gotta just keep moving and I felt
like okay this was part of what Diana
has to learn is that she can't do that
but that shot oh man does patty Jenkins
know how to direct a moment yeah when
she turns around camera circling around
her she turns he has the the like car
aground oh yeah yeah yeah headband she
takes it off she's climbing up the
ladder and then right I started oh man
it happens every time I think about this
magic moment yeah because the IIE
there's something about I tend to cry
more not at loss or death I tend to cry
more at acts of love or heroism yeah in
a movie than than I do tragedy weirdly
that's just what tends to get to me a
little bit more in the film and that act
of heroism heroism was so impactful to
me that when she's walking on that
battlefield because no one having able
to move for a year everyone's saying
they should move on but she's like we
have to save these people and no one is
believe no one cared no not no one cares
but no one is in support of this and the
fact that she's taking the stand to do
what she knows she's capable of doing
this is so [ __ ] beautiful it's so
beautiful that's what doesn't like
belief is mem you know when when they
can really that relate it you know that
somebody who is just invest in something
and giving it their all or you can tell
it means something to them yeah and that
punches me right in the heart you know
oh it does and that whole sequence were
you in the what she has the shield and
she's making progress
like and I love how the team is like
alright I guess we're doing this hitting
and I gotta back her up beeps the reason
making progress to them what I don't
know what's going to happen maybe is
kind of working that let's do it that's
what I love just how Steve Trevor was in
full support of her be like the entire
even when he's questioning her or trying
to get her to change what how she's
thinking like no you guys see from my
perspective when to and she if she makes
a choice he has her back yeah and I love
that I love that character choice of it
and so he had that whole Co securio
entire time with his shield and
everything I was like crying um I mean I
did get a little note in my head of what
boy I didn't want to have made a
difference without the bullets or her
but I did think why isn't anyone shot
her feet nobody does have those like me
high you know metals
I know but everybody likes her revealed
and I kept thinking for a second whether
it was named for the shoes I hang on Amy
burger feet the bloody and bullets going
at her and out yeah yeah but when they
go in and keep Trevor gets to kick some
ass I mean you mean it gets kicks them
after that shotgun of his them is so
badass
like that the team isn't in essential
because well while Diana is doing her
action bits the team's also doing their
cool action stuff like the things that
human beings can do that like maybe you
and I could do if we had enough training
you know that we can do and I'm going to
take care of the big thing you guys take
care of the important small things
around it you know and we saw the scene
we saw that not the whole they didn't
see the whole sequence we saw the
sequence of when she's first running and
the Wonder Woman music starts playing
and then she fights the people in the
room yeah and and then she kicks the guy
needs the guy out of the window and I
was running and then that's all we saw
up to when went to YouTube space
watching it again with its full sequence
its eyes are tearing up because of how
cool is so and like you know this is
this is a new thing the new thing we're
going to do a big deal because this is a
step in a direction yes a choice that we
made and yeah like it's there she's
doing it
and it's so fascinating fascinates me
how they they only use that song in that
one see Valentin the Wonder Woman theme
song that we know now is only used in
that one scene it's not like played
throughout the movie yeah what perfect
scene to choose to use that song Wonder
Woman is gonna go out on her own and
kick some ass yeah bandit you know and
and her warrior song yeah I'm gonna play
and I even like how okay team's doing
their thing Diane is doing her thing but
for the final part when the sniper is
shooting like the whole axis equals how
it's all choreographed and structured
for the final part she has to work
specifically with the team which is they
create the I don't know they give that
big metal gap they order the door they
hold it and add a hop funny thing I know
it didn't kill some snipers boom like
okay yeah so separate separate short
together yeah there is essential team
together then I just love how the phone
beside slowed down but the people
celebrate us let's have Diane alone how
to sway a little bit and create some
chemistry there and then you see Charlie
is playing on the piano and singing the
little character nuances we're so
perfect in felt when I feel like that's
the thing about older war movies is like
you know you have battles and then if
you live you know that'll stops pauses
for me I feel like life can happen
especially if you're traveling you know
like there are at least little moments
in between for life to happen and it's a
really smart choice for this movie to
take because this really also kind of
functions of the war movie oh it is it
is a war it's a war movie it is they
were all about door yeah yeah like even
this Oracle vision yeah even more than I
might say Captain America was like
Captain America the First Avenger sort
of feels like I think back on it and I
think of a severe a movie with with you
know some heavy war elements this one I
was like you're just in the trenches man
yeah thank you no you're you're fighting
the war and montage the war so yeah
exactly in first adventure and then it
becomes a personal you know it's me in
the red skull yeah and Toby Joe yeah but
even this but the scene I really was
moved by as well is when Steve goes to
say goodnight and then he comes back in
like before he closes dirty
he comes back in and he and then Diana
chooses to kiss him the enemies the
first move actually yeah and I love that
moment because usually in these movies
when they bloom they kiss it's like it's
like towards the finale there's big
action going on and [ __ ] pull submit
they got a Chris Pratt and you're [ __ ]
Jurassic world like something like that
is it no that's what I was honestly
thinking that's probably window kisses
like towards the finale when it's a wife
or death you know here's a beat for hope
yeah exactly but in that moment I
believed it and I found a very rewarding
romance that took place and as the film
progresses we get towards the finale you
know they we haven't touched on him at
all or the two villains that are
featured throughout the film general
ludendorf sandy Houston and doctor
poison Elena
aya are you and I yeah we haven't
touched on them at all um there III
excited my non-spoiler I didn't really
believe her and I really felt that they
were that especially general with it's
like I like a villain and maybe the foam
stand out of time for it but I like
Avella Marie could at least kind of
understand where they're coming from
kind of get their motives a little bit I
mean you're dealing with the German
soldiers almost like I'm not gonna get
in a movie like this but I never really
and I just first second was this I think
I couldn't ever see were at all one bit
where he's coming from other than he's
the mean guy is the bad do you got yeah
I mean they're they're shades all I
really wanted more from that was um I
just could have used a couple more seems
to make them human yeah I guess and I
also really quick sorry the power
capsule thing didn't seem that certain
any point to anything I've missed
something in my movie they just made a
comic because I like that I don't think
it served any purpose other than he was
able to fight Diana for a few more
seconds or in the finality I feel like
it was a good tool for the mislead but
um you know it's a good way to make it
so like ah this guy is not invulnerable
but pretty powerful yeah and I don't
necessarily think the choice the ideas
of these characters are bad because you
know I mean we've we've fought two world
wars in Germany was heavily involved in
them and you know nothing not to profile
all Germany but there are certainly
figures in those Wars who wanted you
know to take over the world in a sense
alike with those things in mind I could
get at least on board with it and I
liked I liked their interplay together
that one scene where he again chooses to
empower doctor poison when she's like
really fed up with her work and it's not
working out yeah that sounds like that's
at least one moment where I was like
cool okay I get you guys are working
together and I felt like I like I liked
what they were doing doctor poison a
little more in terms of rides it felt
like she kind of loved him yeah I like
some of the subtle notes of those
characters it's it's just the sort of
like evil plans and cackling that was
like I could use something to ground you
guys and granted is not the point of the
movie and granted they're not even the
big is it added but I would have liked a
little more there was one touch that I
really it seemed a little bit cartoony
but I really liked it when he kills all
the other generals or whatever and then
he throws a gas mask in there because it
kills it with the poison it rose of gas
and asking the - shut the door she's
like the national duty things like that
they don't know that happens there
really I thought I thought that was a
really good moment to me and I wanted a
little more of that yeah but I thought
that was a different life that I wasn't
expecting
well yeah that does those like deranged
love yeah is so invent who or just have
their own little world yeah
and that is that is an actual that again
is cruel but it's a choice to be cruel
it's like we're gonna feed them false
and you know in this moment because also
I get the sense that you know they don't
think very highly of the guys in that
room
No yeah there's a really good good bits
with them and you know knowing at least
we're having the twist rattling around
in my head didn't didn't help no um but
you know I yeah I could have used it
maybe a couple more scenes not totally
yeah
so I mean and then I go to the dancing
which I like a little touch to every
could because one thing I was thinking
of I was sort of thinking about and
sometimes in movies when they you know
when Chris Chris flying is a spy and
oftentimes when people play spies or
they just speak German like I remembered
inglorious basterds
when Michael Fassbender is posing as a
Nazi and he's speaking in German speaks
German fluently but there's a whole
scene dedicated to lies your accent
sound the way it does only so I like the
touch of even though they're speaking
English I thought Chris Pratt Anika
spine is fine I thought Chris Pine did a
great German accent taken and I was like
I believe I believe looks like German
did yeah oh yeah yeah Aryan he really
planted all of his parts really what and
that news I feel like can do accents
this one that I saw him onstage one's
doing a play by Martin McDonagh called
the lieutenant of Inishmore and he was
like hold on Irish brogue the whole show
yeah and he did a great job yeah like
that dude is impressing me the more
Iceland and I like that I like when
things start to go wrong with Diana
where Diana shows up at the party and of
her own sort of arrogance to not listen
and and then she wants to but because
it's like how that there's that scene
where he's kind of seducing doctor
Poisson and he's looking up a diagon's
the room and then poison gets jealous
and walks away because he thinks like oh
he's just attracted to her now and so it
boils the plan with doctor poison that
he had and then he sees it that probably
you don't want to kill this guy yeah
because and that was a nice touch too I
like how we just aggressively grabbed
Diana now that was a cool touch to just
not approach her to have a talking scene
would you like to dance just like Laura
pulls or what are you doing here yeah
and it's the whole touch of them when
their relationship starts to crumble a
little bit because she has a chance to
kill him but but Steve Trevor has a much
bigger plan in mind like if we kill him
we lose all information on everything
and the town dies and that was
heartbreaking the indicator all is lost
moment where the whole village is to
come to the poison they all die but I
like I love the motivating factor of how
Diana is now full of rage because her
rage is building from that point on well
because this is like she starts out this
movie with a very simple plan I'm just
going to gather war binaries kill them
everything's gonna be great and the
whole movies about how unn simple this
is all about to be yeah yeah and then
that's frustrating and I appreciated it
touch 2 of how she just believes the
general dairies yeah because that's just
what she's going to believe you're evil
you must be the Ares guy you're the one
in charge of this you must be Harry yeah
and also I feel like that does help
those elite in character at least a
general ludendorf with that evilness
because you know after a while you
wonder if you've you're a god and you've
been around ever maybe this is just how
you get your kicks yeah exactly exactly
so when she does go to kill who she
blues areas kills Ludendorff he can't
make it the castle thing help for like
five seconds chug
well I'm not going to help him with Dan
being like drove through with a sword
yeah but it was it was an interesting
touch so when she does kill him and then
she's looking around she's like why it
has an evil falling down was wise it's
still continuing why they're still
moving the poison yeah because one of
ours
both of our favorite one of our favorite
scenes is when she is her whole world
shattered like she completes the mission
and it's nothing like what you thought
it would yeah it's not a celebration of
love it's like it's still continuing
yeah I don't understand
and then she learns the life lesson of
this is people and when Steve Trevor the
way Chris Prime delivers that monologue
man of how he was trying to convince
but he's losing hope he has and I like
the touches when people like have that
ironic kind of like laugh was like I
don't tell you anything that was that
was a really heartbreaking moment cuz he
KITT I love how he and I felt like he
added a few touches I got one point
where he puts his hand on her face like
please yeah like I thought now that
touch of crisp Prime probably improvised
there yeah I mean everything of his
feels so natural yeah just damn the wave
like he looks like he's struggling for
words and stuff yeah like he's the is
performance is so human so human and
then of course area shows up actually
one of the one other thing I do think is
kind of at least notable about the whole
like you know power pill is I do think
the contrast helps because it's it is
like when you finally meet some Diana
aid with Diana you know a true demigod
at least you know like it shows like oh
your little castle don't really matter
because you don't know who you're
fighting right yeah so that I thought
was a good touch ok at the good point
what area shows up like as much as I was
upset about you know like the movie news
ruining that plot twist so I I don't
know if it's in the comics where you
pose a Sir Patrick the whole time I
don't know that and the way the film
executes it you're not so you're not
supposed like it is no clear yeah you're
not supposed to know I would you
announce them and yes in that whole
exposition level that's the only time in
the film where I thought you're getting
rather expositional here's an
explanation of who I am yeah oh really
and everything let's cut back to some
flashback moments ago where he whispers
things to be moment stuff like we got to
do a lot of information in here I felt
like if you have this like one more
scene with him earlier had the reveal
come in a little bit or something I felt
it would have just allowed it to keep
the pace moving at the way it was
already moving and also you know does
remind me a little bit of Zod and Clark
when he takes her to the other world
linked with all beautiful again you know
there is a scene in Manistee Oh where as
odd like this is our world Lina and and
and I will say though even though it
does all these things I didn't really
appreciate what I did it pretty shade
was Davis's performance yes I did a
really good job as a growler although
expositional monologue in he was doing a
like delivery is great that like he he's
still a believable I've seen a lot of
this monologue and a he brought a lot of
nuance to it like I know that guy is a
really good actor yeah yeah and I do
like at least the design of him like I
liked that weird even though it does
have kind of my idea of TMNT murder
Michael didn't look like shredder or you
know it kind of reminded me of like the
big metal guy from Suicide Squad yeah
metal guy from Thor yeah Hetal guy from
Iron Man 1 yeah whadaya like it reminded
me of a lot of those but I like the
design the way he did it and and you
know it hearkened to you know some of
that classic imagery like he had kind of
like a war helmet on and also even
coming back to the very front of the
movie when they do that whole montage
that's like a penguin explaining where
the island comes from and everything
yeah with it looks like a classical
painting of Greek mythology like I like
the flourishes that they used Adam yeah
you know and and even you know bringing
that in sort of to his armor and stuff
yeah I mean that's that's a great point
because we even touch on that because
that keeps it in a mythology realm and
then when you cieariy show up it's like
oh this really looks like in real Evans
and it makes it more imposing makes it
more scary as opposed to showing us you
know humans and showing Ares early then
in in real life as opposed to animation
made it that much made it more
intimidating made it more effective what
it's always going to look a little
different like an artist depiction you
look at that that scene is like a moving
painting yeah beautiful to look at and
and then you see what it looks like not
only in real life but also many many
many many many years younger you know
and it does get CGI heavy yeah
that is the issue with it it does go
crazy it but at least it didn't do like
at least it wasn't that general hoo-ha
suddenly has all these powers and he
could take on Diana lucky if I didn't do
that thing yeah I'm glad at least
built-up areas throughout this whole
film and had you wondering like it's
areas even in this film and I yeah so
when he shows up and it kids like what
CGI heavy as it was it's like what makes
sense that it would go this way at the
same time it makes sense that it would
happen yeah I mean it does call for and
I and I feel like the only thing I would
have liked more of for the third act is
I don't think there's a problem that all
of the DC EU movies have for me in I
don't know if I'll call it the third act
but you know like when they start to
reach the second half of the movie the
later parts of the movie the big
climactic fight stunt yes every one of
them for me has flipped a switch
Minnifield partway through four means
the action gets queue you know and BBS
you know especially once doomsday comes
around things get huge and Suicide Squad
Scarlet Witch and the big metal guiding
is way huge way to thing for the movie
enchantress
alright what I say Scarlet Witch I get
those man mixed up all the time and -
Hansel and Gretel witch hunt and then
crow witch hunters same price um but
this one while I think it does still
have some of that it has the least of
all these movies for me where it's like
the finale I think yeah is a little
bloated in terms of like here's a bunch
of exposition of big CG effects and
punch punch punch you know that but um
of all of the DC EU films I think the
finale of this one fits best into its
picture or at least distractingly huge
yeah you know um it was so huge in the
environment it's in yeah not like the
world is about to be destroyed fighting
it like they're they're fighting on you
know they're just fighting on a much
bigger playground right yeah why don't I
have like a piece of a military yeah
something
like as a setting it's not that it's not
like they're throwing each other through
an old things room but if that areas is
all CG I am a water woman get a GI
through a lot of it however there's
still some very powerful touches in that
finale when Steve Trevor goes up and
says things to her and she she can't
hear him then you're like hey look uh
what is it he delivers yeah and how he's
making the choices sacrifice himself
we're gonna blow up the plane um and
that was heartbreaking and when she's
lying down she's like am lovin when she
is when she's lying down and then she
can recall like I don't know how that
happened in but it didn't matter to me
because that was powerful where it plays
an ex-colleague an M night Shyamalan
mystery even even if it's not like I
even if she does remember I feel like
even just as a choice for the movie to
go back and reveal to us what he said
and all that yeah you know like it does
make that that moment really count yeah
and like when he was there was so much
stuff going on that when he was in the
plane I knew he was doing something
important but I wasn't quite sure what
he was up to with that and I was I
thought it made clear to me that like I
was gonna blow up the planes and like
high in sky yeah I maybe I was caught up
in here something is depending on what
the movie is especially movie like this
that I'm like really enthralled by at a
certain point um you stop trying to
predict yeah when in a movie like this I
actually don't like predictions like
people lean over to me and tell me like
this is gonna happen I'm like I don't
want it you're probably right and cool
but you know but I'm so caught up than
on a better way in the moment yeah be
smarter than the movie right now yeah
yeah nothing I could ever hold against
somebody cuz everybody watches a movie
different but you know for me if I'm
invested I'm not trying to crunch the
numbers of the movie so when he actually
when he was like looking back at the
rack of little missiles oh man like that
mom I was like oh he's about to he's
about to do it and the way he played
that to was like you really play like a
guy who's about to you
he's about to meet his fate but he knows
he's doing the right thing stink yeah
anything about all the little the little
gases of this moment and and you can see
the even a little bit of the struggle
because he is not even though he's not a
superhero he's becomes one of the heroes
he met mom
yeah I'm still important he still did
something he still had an impact and it
also added to the effect of Diana
because they don't leashes her Rach or
hurt her pain
you know and that was a really powerful
moment I do I mean as effective as it
was in the moment when she doesn't kill
poison when she doesn't kill doctor
poison I still had one of those and I
thought about it I don't like these you
killed so many other people when it was
one birthday I mean I guess it's
different because you're not trying to
kill her directly at that time or
something well she just innocent she has
a choice to kill her yeah well I think
it's got to do with what she is learning
about this situation yeah yeah sure yeah
they had much to take that areas and
that was a good moment but I like how
the movie ends on kind of a bittersweet
note with he has a loss of Steve Trevor
and I'm glad I just yeah yeah you don't
know everything
yeah and you know I always get what you
want I should have played it maybe now I
will get a look at an ABC series about
future yeah a be cool agent Steve Trevor
but then bringing it back book ending
our spoiler review with the with the
book end of the movie when it came back
to the email would Bruce Wayne I forgot
about that first yeah yeah I was so
pulled into this whole story about like
oh yeah that's right started off here
you know before she has to go play on
stage and when she says thank you for
bringing him back to me I was like just
kind scene yeah yeah yeah it's a
meaningful dish yeah
this photograph actually probably means
yet it means something
I just you know cool email thing from
BBS the hell are you doing yeah picture
cuz it was heartbreaking then when she
wrote that back I was like oh man or
first love
okay yeah and that makes a really hope
they never do some kind of bullet back
from yesterday like resurrect or
something that these but he will know
that it is possible but but yeah like
that made like the combination of I like
it when these movies make a real
sacrifice of a character that you like
yeah we don't want him to die but he has
to die and it's a rewarding I mean yeah
I'm thinking and then and then to have
that yet thanks for bringing him back to
me was a beautiful little [ __ ] for that
you know and then enter a Heath um you
know and then she looks in the camera
weeks yeah it's gonna be awesome
so that was cool apparently she's saving
friends right now that's what happened
right
he's especially donned her suit and Andy
at the end of the movie that she jumps
off the roof or she flies or something I
Anna
oh yeah wedding in France yeah what is
going on at the end of that and I don't
know I always like the like random
Justice League's finding those nebulous
moments at the end of superhero movies
where they're like they're about to
spring into action for what I'm not sure
because it appears as though they want
at the end of this yeah oh my god is she
just going for a stroll one day her and
Bruce Wayne will communicate by phone I
think it's probably safer than email
Lana heaters rolled that on a slip of
paper yeah but yeah that was the movies
amazing fantastic our spoiler review
super freaking long I mean what would
you expect our non-spoiler review is
really long for a film for review dad
knows boy first day and got imagine how
long or suppose it's probably clear that
we just want to talk about this video
it's fantastic it's one of my and that I
don't like questions when I get tweeted
dudes better this was Logan why why why
why are you doing this and I don't think
this movie and Logan are trying to be
the same movie either no it does just
because they fought this genre of
superhero does
mean doesn't mean they should be
compared and that's I think is a good
thing for the superhero genre is the
more of the the more diverse it become
the granted this is I feel like a more
traditional spandex superhero movie with
you know it's a definite we welcome you
know war movie element with that but I
definitely think it's it's more akin to
what you think of when you hear super
movie superhero movie then something
like Logan because by the time the movie
ends
it hits you with a dose of yeah there's
pain involved in being a hero but it's
worth it yeah because sue is down to it
it's not about you with cool powers who
just decided they gotta do something
with them it's like a hero is that is
somebody who tries to do the right thing
out of a compulsion you know yeah yeah
yeah it's it's it's a spirit you know is
a hero yeah spirit in other words top or
whatever it's called because a or take
pump yeah anyway
whoa long talk there subscribe is a real
remeer not Collider media alright be the
real rejects click that notification
build and get notified when every one of
our videos is up Lou gat John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram go check out
our patreon for an exclusive purchase
exclusive rewards exclusive fun random
video content that is not like what you
see on this channel kind of some of it
is somebody's goodbye if they're like
that go see one over theater now